cobit 19 infections and hospitalizations
have been dropping
nationally but some health experts
predict the worst weeks of the virus
might still be ahead
in nevada as elsewhere one of the key
tools in trying to control the spread
has been
contact tracing where those confirmed to
have copied
are contacted by health officials while
employees who have worked inside the
local program
say it is a miserable failure the
i-team's george knapp has our story
tens of thousands of eligible nevadans
have struggled to get appointments for a
cobit vaccination let alone get a second
shot
if you're wondering why the system is so
messed up the seeds may have been
planted
11 months ago when the health district
struggled to implement
basic plans including a program for
contact tracing
there's been so many delays where by the
time you reach people
that are positive it's already too late
they're already
well again and we can't even
begin to imagine how far it's spread to
other people until a few months ago john
worked for the southern nevada health
district as a contact tracer
each day he was assigned a file of 10 to
20 cases
people who had tested positive for covet
it was his job to contact the infected
person
and identify who else may have been
infected in practice he says
tracers were never able to finish their
daily lists
the delays between the time people were
tested and when they were informed of
the results grew from days
to weeks to a month or more sometimes we
had no idea
that the person has already died so
you're calling the family to tell them
hey you test positive
but they're already dead that's right
what's the reaction been like from the
family members
it's been a mix of anger sad
upset looking for someone to blame by
september john says the backlog for
contact tracers
was 15 thousand infected people who had
not been contacted
then it grew to 25 000. james is another
former health district employee
who confirmed the size of the backlog
and the chaos within the district um
it's just a disaster
it started from the beginning
where there just wasn't never enough
contact tracers
and once there's not enough contact
tracers
then it just gets more and more behind
and then it just becomes where contact
tracing
is useless contacting people
that showed positive a month ago
it doesn't do anything although contact
tracing has worked well in other
countries it's been a failure across
much of the u.s
in part because americans find it
intrusive or believe the virus is a hoax
or simply don't answer the phone
epidemiologist dr arturo moretto says
one reason the local health district
hasn't stood out as a miserable failure
is because so many other health
districts have done poorly as well
but you know it's leading good thing for
the health district the whole nation
is uh not you know doing well and that's
the only thing that is actually maybe
that they can use an excuse
arturo moretto spent almost 10 years
with the health district and specialized
in contact tracing
specifically for hiv cases it works he
says
but not as implemented for kovit many of
the senior managers at the district
were hired or promoted by former chief
joe iser
not for their expertise or training he
says but for their loyalty to icer
moreno says he discovered the district
making inflated claims to the state
about the success of its contact tracing
after he reported it to the state he was
fired because
they were claiming fifteen twenty
percent of the cases were being found
or identified through contact racing and
that was an absolute light moreto has
previous experience as a whistleblower
at the health district and has spoken
out about senior managers
lacking the most basic credentials for
dealing with infectious diseases
more on that in the days ahead george
knapp 8 news now
now george sought an interview with the
health district but the district
declined
a spokesperson did answer several
questions that we submitted in writing
saying the contact tracing program has
been able to quote
adequately respond to cobit except
during the summer surge of cases end
quote
you can read the full response on our
website